(gentle classical music)
- This particular story
is just special in that it
occurred at a very particular
moment in our history,
in the history of the
Civil Rights Movement,
and it kind of linked
together what was happening
in this country as well
as that spirit of freedom
that was also sweeping across
Africa at the same time.
We started planning it
six or nine months ago.
Now there was quite a number of things.
So we had obviously the
beautiful dress that Jacquelyn
Kennedy wore that evening.
The gifts that the
president of the Ivory Coast
presented to President Kennedy
and then just some of the
documents that show the meticulous
planning that went into this
event and really all of the
state events that are planned
mostly by the first lady.
Her touch was really on every detail.
Our collection holds
about 60 or 65 dresses.
And it's a particularly
beautiful one, it's sparkly,
and glittery, and it
really speaks to the glamor
and kind of the formality
and the dignity of
a state event.
A state event is always a
way for the host country
to kind of show off the
best of their country
and so our hope is that
people will come and see these
original things and it
just reminds them that oh
President Kennedy and
Mrs. Kennedy occupied the
White House.
They were, you know these
are the actual things,
the physical materials
that they you know touched
and used and that chronicle
the things they accomplished
in the White House.
(dramatic music)